hard to imagine a time when police in
America had been under more scrutiny
than they are today but this country has
a long fascinating and challenging
history with law enforcement both trying
to build it up and change it to get a
better sense of how we arrived at this
moment we traveled to a place at the
center of police history to see what's
evolved and what many believe still
needs to there's 21,000 names that are
on these walls here
people have lost their lives law
enforcement officers who have lost their
lives
Michael Chapman has had just about every
law enforcement job in the book
local police DEA agents SWAT team member
Homeland Security now three term County
Sheriff in Virginia as you've seen all
of these protests unfold on television
what protocol is through your mind I
think it's sad I think it's sad because
I would say that what happened up in
Minneapolis set us back 20 or 30 years
we met Chapman at the National Law
Enforcement Museum in Washington DC
Chapman was first hired as a cop in 1978
more than 350 years after the first
small sheriff's office was established
in America America has always had a very
decentralized policing system reliance
on local levels right has that been good
or bad for this country I think it's
important that it's decentralized
because really when you look at the
communities and local law enforcement
they're really a composite of that
community local sheriff's departments
evolved from community watches and could
go in dramatically different directions
beginning in the 1700s in the province
of Carolina and spreading throughout the
south slave patrols were created to
prevent rebellions and enslaved people
from escaping the first city police
departments were formed in the mid 19th
century Boston first then New York in
many cases to deal with public
drunkenness and social disorder but the
police often became tools of corruption
for local politicians
[Music]
please work efforts at reform in the
twentieth century gave departments more
autonomy but also led to increases in
tactics like stop-and-frisk alienating
minority communities in particular often
leading to violent confrontations the
results of which we still see today law
enforcement has changed dramatically in
the last 200 years
Scot habes is the chief curator at the
National Law Enforcement Museum which is
everything from Bonnie and Clyde's tommy
gun to the original Robocop costume used
in the 1987 film about a future
dominated by machine instead of man
Robocop is interesting because it again
allows people to think about policing in
terms of advancements and technology and
what that means for the future
technology advancing but they're also
still has to be a humanity to it right
which i think is apropos to in terms of
this policing still involves human
beings and relationships and I think
that will never change
hey showed us some other items as well
including a noise maker used by the
earliest police forces to summon help
the Hat worn by Osama bin Laden when he
was killed and what is this this looks
like a lightsaber it doesn't it's
actually from the 1920s originally and
what it is is a combination baton and
teargas thrower and it was actually used
straight through the 1960s in the
protest the famous protests of the 60s
this museum has examples of the good and
the bad yes it does and I think that's
an ongoing conversation that we're
trying to update as we speak
you know part of our mandate is to
envision the future of law enforcement
and to also improve the relationship
between law enforcement and the
communities they serve as it stands
today there are more than 18,000 federal
state and local law enforcement agencies
in the u.s. that includes more than
750,000 sworn officers the Chapman says
they're supposed to protect all 330
million Americans regardless of place or
time
you know a few weeks ago before
Minneapolis the law enforcement dealing
with kovat 19 and first responders
dealing with kovat 19 people are coming
by they're bringing as donuts or
bringing us sandwiches or bringing
everything we were heroes okay a couple
weeks later we're villains I mean so I
think the the public tends to go up and
down on things but we need to make sure
that people understand that we try to do
our job professionally correctly we take
it very seriously and we really do want
to serve the citizens to the best of our
ability when you hear the slogan defund
police what do you think I just think it
makes no sense at all we have to make
sure that there is some protection for
the safety of our citizens and law
enforcement historically has been the
best way to do that there are some
argument that it's not defunding the
police we just want to reallocate
resources what do you think of that if
you look at what's happened over time
you know actually law enforcement has
become like the mental health
professionals and our jails have become
the mental health facilities and it's
largely because we're available
you know 365 days a year 24 hours a day
seven days a week you're gonna have
mistakes but for the most part we do
pretty well what change do you think
needs to happen I think we need to
continue to work in a direction that we
have been de-escalation techniques
making sure that we're working with our
community really getting to understand
what they're about see what church
groups you have with different community
groups you have we have multicultural
groups that were part of so we're we're
really engaged with the community and I
think that goes a long way
community policing he talked about
Michelle as you know really began to
rise in the 80s and it's a trend that
continues to this day and I think when
Chapman talked about the mental health
part about it it's it's pretty
fascinating to think about what what
police are doing now and what they may
have done 40 or 50 years ago if they saw
someone on the street who's in crisis
and there's a problem 40 or 50 years ago
maybe foreign handcuffs arrested today
most
try to take a different approach doesn't
always work but that's the approach so
much to say about this and it's a long
discussion and we must contain you thank
you Jeff important insightful